okay so we have the boolean part of this
question place to one side let's have a
look at what they're asking for us next
unit sir ah now interesting yeah suppose
sure well okay um they're actually going
to give us units in a second ah
interestingly this this you'll notice no
units have been provided yet and they
provide it sort of yeah right at the end
like right the very end of the question
so at the moment I'm happy I'm content
to just leave this as an expression
right because it's an integral so as an
integral and something doesn't need to
have units attached to it and i'll bring
the unitive as i require them ok so the
cap represents a shallow puddle of water
left after some rain like last night
when the Sun comes out the water
evaporates at a rate proportional to its
surface area just hold on for a second
what does that mean ok so if I have a
lot of water in here ok all of the parts
that's where the water is actually
you're escaping out into the air is from
this surface right like this the bigger
the surface area the more places there
are is my you know betraying how little
I know about sides there's more places
for the water to escape off of is a lot
more place for them the window by path
etc you can imagine obviously if say my
shape were like upside down or even if
it was something simple like say am a
silicon ok when you have a look at the
water that's in there if I put in an
amount of water in them in this
container here the surface area is going
to always be the same right as this gets
lower and lower and lower but associate
always be the same so this is going to
evaporate at a constant rate but this is
not is it right as this gets lower lower
lower there's less surface area so
there's less space for to evaporate from
so this rate of change is going to be
very yeah and that's what makes this an
interesting question so just keep that
in your head for a second and now let's
have a look at how to actually get
towards this expression so part I for
pop your pop what I should say is what
is this surface area so where is this
this area on our diagram on here
unfortunately the surface area is that
on this diagram right because what we
did was we we made it flat so we could
work out all this other stuff so that's
why you need this diagram right does
that make sense so I'm going to get rid
of these areas now it's not very helpful
this efforts area is just this some just
a circle top yeah so I'm going to put on
other fronts not very straight line
right and I want to work out what that
is that's the radius okay the radius is
obviously the single piece of
information I need for that surface area
yes we will in fact that's exactly what
I'm going to do the 2d diagram has
information on it which is what i'm
going to use so you can see this are
right corresponds to this distance in
here bears are right and i like having
both of these diagrams beside each other
because they mutually inform each other
so how do i find what r is all this
diagram what am I gonna use yeah
substitute negative
undersized okay so a pressure of what I
can take is this distance here is the
same as the x coordinate of that spot do
you agree that could work I could put
your negative hedge into the equation in
the circle and it would give me a number
it would work but I think there's a
simpler way isn't that yeah I have a
right angle triangle here there he is
right and I know everything I need to
know about this right angle triangle
it's the hypotenuse is the radius of
this circle so it must be equal to
fourth we start off just buying to find
that as H right so i would of course get
the same expression for all I need to
say is in this triangle um r square + H
square equals 4 squared do you agree
come in to really take asleep of course
the reason for this is pat my dressing
rooms I'm you say that
so what did I want one thing I want I
wanted ah so i'll put R squared first
like so so I have this yeah what do you
think now I would point out um you know
the suggestion we had before I'll put it
into this equation is going to give you
exactly that like it's just the x
coordinate that I want it's the same
thing it's the same equation you know as
it happens I don't actually need our I
don't I don't I didn't need are right
this is one of those helpful times where
it's important to recognize like you
know we say our simplified right and
earlier on it your mathematical career
simplify is just whatever the teacher
told you to do right but as we go
further it's like well simplify beans
just get it into whatever for I want it
to be to do the next thing what was the
next thing why are we working with our
infant yeah I actually wanted to marry a
right which I don't need up for our
squid is just fine yeah so I'm actually
going to rewind away and I'm just going
to say well what I'm actually working
out is this surface area of course the
circle which is just pi r square so that
area butter is this yeah it x